we're going to do some quick breaking
news before we go to the break because
we've had that Phillip Schofield
statement in the last few minutes in an
hour an hour ago just before this
morning went on air
um he put up a an insta story and Eman
Holmes has replied let me actually um
yeah okay so this is Eamonn Holmes's
tweet Schofield has just put out a
delusional statement like Holly he puts
it on instant stories so if it goes
wrong there's no record after 24 hours
because those incest stories they only
stay up for 24 hours Eamon goes on to
say I'm reluctant to give the liar any
more publicity but believe me pip if you
are looking for a fight you have picked
on the wrong person so that is Eamonn
Holmes tweet in the last couple of
minutes and I'm going to read You
Phillip schofield's
um insta story so that you have some
context for that let me get it up hang
on a second
can we get that graphic up because I'm
trying to find it
okay there it is um so this was the
insta story now I no longer work on this
morning I'm free to say this I hope
you've noticed that it's the same
handful of people with a grudge against
me or the show who seem to have the
loudest voice this morning is the best
show to work on with the best people in
all the years I worked there there was
no toxicity you can listen to those
persistence persistently loud voices if
you like but the thousands of guests
over the years thousands of staff and
crew hundreds of presenters and
contributors all know it is a family of
wonderful kind talented hard-working
people so the row goes on Eamonn Holmes
tweeting in response to that insta story
from Philip schofields